bonjour à tous mardi noir en perspective
RMC mobilisée pour cette 6e journée
d'action contre la réforme des retraites
avec de nombreuses difficultés à prévoir
dans les transports en commun Stéphane
et Sévery en pleine forme qui cherchait
des galères partout mais à chaque fois
même constat en fait tout allait bien on
voulait voir comment ça se passe sur le
périph et ben ça roule plutôt bien on se
fait klaxonner avec des grands signes
comme ça donc c'est plutôt sympa il y a
pas grand monde dans cette station Total
de la Porte de Saint-Cloud à Paris une
annonce de la CGT qui indique que les
expéditions de carburant sont bloqués ce
matin dans toutes les raffineries de
France la CGT qui voulait que plus
aucune goutte de carburant ne sortent ce
matin alors samedi vous êtes allés faire
les courses vous avez pris cher et ben
demain c'est mardi et c'est Macron qui
va prendre cher aujourd'hui des foules
de manifestants qui ont des chaînés dans
les rues contre la réforme des retraites
pour cette 6e journée de mobilisation
ils étaient 700 000 à Paris d'après la
CGT beaucoup beaucoup moins pour la
préfecture qui a compté 81 000 personnes
parce que on peut dire que plusieurs
milliers de personnes sont présentes à
Nice ce matin
oui jusqu'ici le pic avait été atteint
le 31 janvier puis la mobilisation avait
un peu faibli notamment pendant les
vacances d'hiver le 16 février il faut
croire que l'appel des syndicats a été
entendu aujourd'hui la France à la race
c'est le slogan Amandine Atalaya de
cette journée d'action alors c'est plus
nuance et que ça disons qu'il y a
beaucoup de d'actions de voir de blocage
de la parler d'une interruption totale
de de du pays on n'y est pas non
[Musique]
effectivement par mettre à genoux
d'économie française
je pense que quand on entend un leader
syndical parler de maître l'économie de
notre pays à genoux je pense que c'est
grave et que ça n'est pas responsable et
que les premiers qui se serait pénalisés
si on met l'économie de notre pays à
genoux ce sont les plus modestes les
plus fragiles dans notre pays ah non on
peut tourner la caméra là personne
personne sur lequel toi la greffe
j'adore l'école madame la Première
ministre vous ne pouvez pas gouverner
seul contre tout le monde il n'y a pas
de 49,3 contre l'Union Populaire il n'y
a pas de honte à reculer d'autres l'ont
fait avant vous donc là il y a quand
même un petit problème depuis le début
vous nous dites on travaille sur le tail
son travail on l'arrange on l'amende etc
plus vous la vendez et plus elle se vide
de sa substance
non c'est pas de levier
les choses au contraire il y a un
déficit désormais Olivier du socle l'a
reconnu lui-même ce week-end et le refus
du gouvernement de dire c'est un seul et
même problème c'est l'inflation c'est le
coup de la vie c'est qu'on en peut plus
etc c'est le problème de la répartition
des richesses du pays le trou dans le
système de retraite est très inférieur
aux dividende d'un seul groupe en France
LVMH et c'est à partir
on est sur un déficit de 200 à 300
millions d'euros par an est-ce qu'il
faut l'améliorer pendant ce temps les
sénateurs ont planché sur l'examen de
cette réforme des retraites jusqu'à 3h
cette nuit et ils ont rejeté toutes les
propositions de taxation des super
profits ou des dividendes qui ont été
présentés par la gauche c'est le nerf de
la guerre au moment où les syndicats
veulent mobiliser sur la durée la grève
coûte cher évidemment c'est un coup
puisqu'on a une journée de salaire en
moins on n'est pas payé mais on s'en
fout on est prêt à perdre cet argent
pour gagner au final sur la retraite je
veux d'abord qu'on ait une pensée pour
toutes ces personnes
qui font le sacrifice d'une journée de
salaire de deux journées de salaire pour
être dans cette lutte qui est d'intérêt
général et qui est destiné à tout le
monde des appels au don qui viennent
nourrir des cagnottes plus de 600000
euros déjà ce matin sur celle de la CGT
et cet argent est redistribué au
grévistes au cas par cas tout dépend du
nombre de jours de grève tu demanderas
actif dans les camarades on va plus
facilement redistribuer avec camarades
qui vivent au SMIC avec les camarades
qui gagnent 3000 3500 euros par mois
tout ça se trouve travailler quand vous
êtes étudiant
mais vous pouvez vous toucher et vous
connaissez le prix de l'immobilier
parisien mais vous attend
au lycée donc des anciens élèves qui ont
eu leur bac et qui me recontacte ensuite
deux trois ans
on a tous été étudiants dans une chambre
de bonne en arrivant à Paris et on a un
gouvernement qui est un président de la
République surtout qui
ne prête pas attention revendications on
le voit sur une vidéo qui circule sur
les réseaux sociaux
pour autant une bière chemise ouverte
manche relevée en compagnie d'une star
de la chanson congolaise Fally
Ipupa exactement bah tiens il est
pépouse notre Président vous voyez les
images florales
sur RMC story est-ce qu'on s'en fout ou
pas
le ministre de la Justice a adressé deux
bras d'honneur dans l'hémicycle au
président du groupe les républicains
Olivier Marley qui venait de lui
rappeler à la tribune sa mise en examen
reprise et légale d'intérêt de garder
sauts ensuite dire regretter ce geste et
à présenter ses excuses
je trouve que les humains j'ai une
carrière
moi partir de 14 15 ans je suis beaucoup
sorti
[Rires]
des cagnottes en ligne et des caisses de
grève sont déjà ouvertes évidemment ça
nous inquiète l'essence mais quelle est
l'image que
la fille de cet assassin qui était Che
Guevara mais c'est fascinant Che Guevara
c'est une horreur absolue mais ça c'est
votre point de vue
[Musique]
syndical venait prendre la parole avec
une photo d'Adolf Hitler
je ne compare pas de Che Guevara c'est
Donald Trump que l'on entend parce que
Donald Trump a participé au projet dans
cette chanson on l'entender le sergent
le sergent le serment d'allégeance au
drapeau américain c'est un texte auquel
on sait qu'il est très attaché qu'il y
avait d'ailleurs rythmé son mandat
l'ancien président a spécifiquement
enregistré cette déclaration depuis sa
résidence de Mare à Lago donc clairement
il fait partie intégrante du projet 300
ans c'est notre chiffre du jour si rien
n'est fait il faudra 300 ans pour
parvenir à l'égalité homme-femme un
chiffre brandit par l'ONU et par son
secrétaire général Antonio Gutierrez qui
estime que dans bien des pays comme en
Afghanistan la condition des femmes est
piétinée la lutte pour l'égalité semble
hélas patiner